angela merkel ist zu weihnachten noch
bundeskanzlerin
[Applaus]
es durch einen weichenstellungen
vorgenommen werden wir müssen die frage
wer zahlt die krise beantworten können
und es muss ein sofortprogramm geben was
die maßnahmen den klimawandel wirklich
einzudämmen deutlich machen
fakt ist es muss ein politikwechsel
geben und er muss ich sehr sehr stark
auf dem sozialen gebiet wieder spielen
also meine prognose ist dass es sehr
lange dauern wird weil es wird
vermutlich keine partei auch nur in die
nähe von 30 prozent kommen und das wird
dazu führen dass es diverse
koalitionsoptionen geht und da wird man
auch ein großes taktisches verhalten
gesehen meine einschätzung ist angela
merkel ist zu weihnachten noch
bundeskanzlerin
[Applaus]